is Ms something that people can live
long lives because I remember my friend
his mom had Ms when I was young and she
had it for like 40 or 50 like 50
years yeah when I was
diagnosed and I don't know if every
neurologist would say the same but I'm
very appreciative that the man that
diagnosed me said there's no reason to
think that you can't live a very healthy
and long life like this isn't a death
sentence you know medicine has come a
long way and ways of supporting and
slowing down the progression of the
disease and it's you know it's still
very individual um it's
still I have good days and bad days in
that like I can still do all of the same
things which is why I'm very confident
working like I don't feel like I'm going
to wake up one day and be like guys I
can't really
walk it's not that it's how I feel
internally is my good days or bad days
which look we all have that I can
through and some days I don't have to
push through as much
um I think where I get the most sad
sometimes is like man this this could be
forever for the rest of my life that I
have to live with this that's what
that's where I can get a little sad like
it's G to it's going to be a little hard
forever probably yeah but I mean with
technology and the way things are moving
who knows I mean why couldn't they why
aren't they able to reverse it I mean
I'm surprised they haven't been able to
do that yet and Alzheimer's and all
these things are so tragic it's like
we're waiting we're waiting for that you
know and when it h it could I think it
will happen I do too I really do I do
too and um I do too it'd be magical I do
too I think so you have to always have
hope and it's not false hope because
it's it's not like we're in the [__]
1700s and you don't know what the hell's
going on have a l of Hope but I think
that I have learned that it's better to
not think about that too much because it
can take me so far away from what it is
now it the the more accepting I am
getting in the
now the less pressure I feel about it
yeah you don't want it to consume you
you're like hey I can't well they always
say you know if you can't control
something if you can't change something
shove it
if you can't change or control something
shove it because it's not you can't do
anything about responsibility I can't
when that time comes I do the best I can
to take care of myself the best way
possible